So let's see if we can compute
the size of the flat page table.
Let's say that the page table
needs to have 8 bytes per entry.
For example, because it has
a 64-bit physical address space.
Let's say that the page size is 4 kB.
Let's say that the system only has
two processes that are active.
Let's say that the system only
really has 2 GB of physical memory.
Let's say that the programs
are creating 32-bit virtual addresses.
Let's say that the process number one
is using only 1 MB of it's available
32-bit address space.
And let's say that process number two
is using 1 GB of its virtual memory.
It could use up to 4 GB but
it's only using 1 GB.
The question for you is,
what is the total size of all the page
tables in the system, in megabytes?